[music]
Hallelujah.
>> [music]
>> Hey,
hey, hey.
Home.
Two beasts become friends.
That's the topic of today's lecture. And
the question is who are these two beasts
and how does it impact upon us? Well, we
can only understand these beasts if we
have studied Daniel chapter 7 where the
attributes of this beast are explained
to us. Now, we're not doing Daniel
chapter 7 because we're doing a
revelation seminar. There is, however, a
whole video on that subject. In Daniel
chapter 7, the attributes of the beast
power are given. There it is described
as a horn, which is also in Daniel a
political entity or a king. a king or a
kingdom.
And this power would be diverse from the
first, different to all the other kings.
Now, if you study Daniel 7, you'll see
that the attributes given there will be
taken up again in Revelation 13. So, the
same system will be described in a
different format in Revelation
chapter 13. But what is interesting
about this political entity is that it's
different from all the others. And the
reason why it is different because it's
also ecclesiastical. It is also a
religious system because its main
emphasis is religion. It has a quarrel
with the saints of the most high and it
is blasphemous towards the most high.
Daniel 7:25 says, "And he shall speak
great words against the most high and he
shall wear out the saints." So this has
a politic agenda and it has a religious
agenda of the most high and think to
change times and laws. It'll change the
times and it will change the laws.
Fascinating. If you think about this
system and this system apply can apply
only to one institution and that is
Rome. No other institution covers every
single aspect of the little horn power.
We haven't got time to go into all the
details. It has changed the times and it
has changed the laws. The laws of God
and the times of God. We'll come to that
a little later. and they shall be given
into his hand until the time and times
and the dividing of times. We pick this
prophecy up in Revelation 11 where they
would have controlling power for these
three and a half prophetic years, the
1,260
prophetic days, the 1,260
literal years.
Now the beast of revelation 13 is a
conglomerate of what we had in Daniel
chapter 7. There are various aspects
surrounding this animal. It has the head
of a lion, the mouth of a lion. Now
lion, the lion represented Babylon in
Daniel chapter 7. Then it has the feet
of a bear and the bear represented Meido
Persia. And then it has the body of this
leopard and the leopard represents
Greece in Daniel chapter 7. And then it
has the 10 horns and these seven heads.
And this these 10 horns represent uh the
10 kingdoms that we have in terms of the
creatures in Daniel chapter 7 and the
toes of the statue in Daniel chapter 2.
So this is a conglomerate beast having
components philosophies if you like of
Meo Persia, Greece, Rome and uh Babylon
and it speaks with a mouth of a lion. So
it speaks Babylonian language.
And I stood upon the sand of the sea and
I saw a beast arise out of the sea. Sea
nations, peoples, multitudes, the waters
that you saw. So it comes out amongst
the nations having seven heads, 10 horns
and upon its horns 10 crowns
and upon his head the name of blasphemy.
There you have the link with Daniel
chapter 7. This blasphemous power that
is against the most high comes up
amongst the nations. And in Daniel
chapter 7 we see that it comes up in
Rome in the Roman Empire and
particularly the western Roman Empire.
And this influence would spread across
the entire world. And the beast which I
saw was like unto a leopard. It
therefore has Greece in it. It has
Grecian philosophy if you like. And uh
the Roman church certainly has uh the
philosophy of the Greeks in it because
it uh supports Aristotle and all of
these great philosophers and Oregon and
all the Greek scholars that arrived
later in the Roman Empire are also
represented and his feet were as the
feet of a bear. Does Rome have Meoersian
philosophy? Absolutely. Mitraism
is the main thrust of the religion. It
even has the triple crown which comes
from Meo Persia. And the mouth was the
the mouth of the lion is the Babylonian
religion of Isis and Osiris of Baal and
Ashtaret. Are all these religions
embodied in it? The answer is yes. If we
go to Babylon, the lion was a symbol of
Babylon. But the sad story is that the
dragon gave him his power and his seat
in great authority. Revelation
chapter 1 and two complete or verses one
and two tell us the sad story that
behind this power is the dragon and the
dragon is none other than the devil.
Revelation 12:9 identifies the dragon as
Satan. But Satan works through human
agencies. In Revelation 12, the dragon
worked through pagan Rome and attempted
to destroy Jesus. Was a Roman official
who tried to kill the baby Jesus, a
governor who condemned Jesus, an
executioner who crucified him, an emblem
sealed his tomb, and a god watched his
tomb. So there is the Roman aspect. And
there was given unto him a mouth
speaking great things and blasphemies.
So this religious political entity would
blaspheme God
and power was given him to continue 40
and two months. There is the 42 month
period. 42 * 30 prophetic days is 1,260
days. And he opened his mouth in
blasphemy against God to blasphe his
name. That's the character of God. and
his tabernacle that's the sanctuary
service that means the path of salvation
which is explained there robs people of
the saving power of Jesus Christ has
this power done this yes is that
substituted saints and Mary and all
kinds of intermediaries even the church
itself and its uh delegates to mediate
on behalf of man and them that dwell in
heaven and thus they blasphem the very
God of heaven. Revelation 135 and 6. And
power was given unto him to continue 40
and two months. Revelation 13:5. So it
would do this openly publicly for those
42 prophetic months. 42 months. 42* 30.
1,260
days a day for a year. I've given you a
day for your year. Ezekiel 4:6. That
brings us to the same story that we
found in Revelation 11 where Vigilus
ascended the papal chair 538 AD under
the protection of Belisarius. That's
history. So we have a starting date when
the papacy started to exercise the power
from the decree that Justinian had
issued giving it the power to correct
all heretics. those who dared to think
for themselves.
So the legally recognized supremacy of
the pope began in 538 AD and then went
into effect the emperor's uh decree as I
have said where he was the corrector of
heretics. So Rome today still claims to
be the sole one who can determine what
you should believe because the papacy
claims infallibility
and cannot make a mistake on doctrinal
issues. Uh Labanka, professor of history
at the University of Rome says to the
succession of the Caesars came the
succession of the pontiffs in Rome. When
Constantine left Rome, he gave his seat
to the pontiff. This is based on the
so-called letters of Constantine which
are forgeries and have been proved to be
such but nevertheless that is the story.
The transfer of the emperor's residence
to Constantinople was a sad blow to the
prestige of Rome and at the time one
might have predicted her speedy decline.
But the development of the church and
the growing authority of the bishop of
Rome or the pope gave her a new lease of
life and made her again the capital this
time the religious capital of the
civilized world. That's Abbott's Roman
history. That is just a fact. The Bible
says and it was given unto him to make
war with the saints and to overcome them
and power was given him over all
kindreds and tongues and nations. That
is a prophetic statement. This system
will control
how much of the world?
>> All of it. All of it. So power was given
over the saints during the 1,260
year period. But this power would
control the whole world.
Stanley's history says the popes filled
the place of the vacant emperor at Rome,
inheriting their power, prestige, titles
from paganism. Constantine left all to
the bishop of Rome which is not true but
nevertheless the papacy is about but the
ghost of the deceased Roman Empire
sitting crowned upon its grave. So we
have an emperor. He even has the title.
He even has the title Pontifix Maximus
which belonged to the Roman emperor. So
in effect the pope is the emperor of
Rome today. Has the church persecuted
western watchman Catholic source? Yes.
It doesn't deny that it has persecuted,
that it has used the severest penalties,
even death, and had the state execute
these penalties. I saw one of his heads,
as it were, wounded to death. So, there
is a mortal wound, and his deadly wound
was healed, and some in the world
wondered after the beast.
>> Oh, no, it doesn't say that. It says,
"All the world wondered after the
beast." Now, this over here is a very
interesting statement. I saw one of his
heads as it were
wounded to death. Some translations say
seemed to have a mortal wound. Is there
a difference between seemed or as it
were and had a mortal wound? Yes or no?
Yes. So, it seemed to have a mortal
wound, but maybe that was deception.
Maybe it just copied Jesus Christ.
Because if this is antichristto,
antichrist in the place of Jesus Christ,
it follows the whole concept. This
system has placed itself as the
mediator. This system forgives the sins.
This system gives you a new lease of
life. opens the door to heaven or to
hell and this system also receives a
wound and is resurrected. So it is a
counterfeit of Christ if you like but it
seems to have a mortal wound. So that is
the 1,260ear
period 538 to 1798.
One of the heads seemed to have a mortal
wound. So in this time period it seems
to die but it doesn't really die. It
actually goes underground but as a beast
it dies because it loses political power
and then that political power will be
given back and there is a resurrection
of this beast. This is what the Bible is
saying. So in 1798
remember Bertia made his entrance into
Rome. He abolished the papal government.
Napoleon with his Freemason army if you
like established a secular government.
So says the encyclopedia Britannica
leaving the Freemason stuff out. Bertier
entered Rome on the 10th of February
1798 and proclaimed the republic thus
fulfilling this prophecy to the letter.
Half of Europe thought Napoleon's veto
would be obeyed and that with the pope
the papacy was dead. modern papacy,
Reverend Joseph Ricky. It's like quoting
the Bible.
So, exactly 1,260
days. The murder of a Frenchman in Rome
in 1798 gave the French the excuse to
enter.
Church history says, "And they carried
him off into exile, the pope, and the
beast received a mortal wound. And I saw
one of the heads as it were wounded to
death and his deadly wound was healed
and all the world wandered after the
beast. Now surely that's not possible.
Not everybody's going to follow
Catholicism,
Revelation 13:3, or are they? That's the
question we have to ask. Remember the
San Francisco Chronicle article where it
said the Vatican was at peace with Italy
and the autographs both sides were very
cordial to one another and the wound was
healed between the two. Revelation 13:7
says, "And power was given him over all
kindreds and tongues and nations."
That's scary. Rome will control the
entire world. That's what it says.
So a universal religious power
controlling the conscience of the entire
world. That's what the promise is. And
they worship the dragon. So if you
follow the system unwittingly,
you are actually worshiping the dragon
which gave power unto the beast because
it is a deception. Jesus Christ has been
replaced by this antichristto system
something in the place of Jesus Christ
and they worship the beast. So the beast
receives homage and we have a father son
sort of system here saying who is like
unto the beast who is able to make war
with him. So if you oppose it do you get
obliterated by war probably.
And he opened his mouth in blasphemy
against God to blasphe his name and his
tabernacle. We've discussed that
already. That's the ministry of Christ.
And them that dwell in heaven, God
himself is blasphemed. Jesus is removed
in their writings. And all that dwell
upon the earth shall worship him whose
names are not written in the book of
life of the lamb, slain from the
foundation of the world. Revelation 13:4
to8. So don't you think it is important
that Roman Catholics should know that if
they are in this system and knowingly
cooperate with this system that they are
actually worshiping the dragon?
I was pleased when I found this out.
Know ye not that to whom you yield
yourselves servants to obey his servants
are ye whom you obey
whether of sin unto death or obedience
unto righteousness. Romans 6:16. So if
you allow obey the system, well then you
are part of it. For thou said in thy
heart, I will ascend into heaven. I will
exalt my throne above the stars of God
and I will be like the most high. He
wants the worship. So if we worship the
system, we're actually worshiping the
dragon. The pope has been man of the
earth and uh prophets I believe have
looked down the stream of time. Billy
Graham said he'll go down in history as
the greatest of modern popes.
Fascinating.
He really will. He has a will and a
determination to help humanity through
spirituality.
Well, maybe that should be corrected and
say spiritualism.
That is marvelous. That is good. I know
how difficult it is for leaders on these
issues. Thus sayeth the Dalai Lama.
Now what is this about blasphemy?
Revelation 13:6, he opened his mouth in
blasphemy. Daniel 7:25, he shall speak
great words against the most high. What
does it mean to speak great words
against the most high? There are two
definitions in the Bible. John chapter
10:33.
And the Jews answered him, saying, "For
a good work we stone thee not, but for
blasphemy, because thou being a man,
make thyelves God." So if you say, "I'm
God," that's blasphemy.
Who opposes and exalted himself above
all that is called God or that he's
worshiped, so that he as God sitth in
the temple of God, showing himself that
he is God. 2 Thessalonians 2:4
describing the antichrist power saying
that it is God and taking the place of
God. He'll do the forgiveness of sins.
He'll do these things and the other
things. So the Bible defines blasphemy
as assuming any right or power that
belongs to God alone.
Now let's read papal statements.
Ferraris ecclesiastical dictionary. The
pope is of so great dignity and so
exalted that he's not a mere man but as
it were God and the vicer of God. So
there's a papal statement where the pope
as he claims to be God just like the
Roman emperor claimed to be God. So he
sets it himself. Pope Leo said, "We hold
upon this earth the place of God
Almighty."
Here's another definition of blasphemy.
Luke 5:21 and the scribes and the
Pharisee began to reason, saying, "Who
is this who speaks blasphemy? Who can
forgive sins but God alone? So if you
say you can forgive sins, that's
blasphemy.
For there is one God and one mediator
between God and men, the man Christ
Jesus, says 1 Timothy 2:5. Now here
comes another system and uh the pope
says in the on the authority of the
councils, all names which in the
scripture are applied to Christ by
virtue of which it is established that
he is over the church. All the same
names are applied to the pope. So the
papacy takes the place of Jesus Christ
and they claim God himself is obliged to
abide by the judgment of his priests and
either not to pardon or to pardon
according as they refuse or give
absolution. The sentence of the priest
precedes and God subscribes to it. Wow.
Dignity and duty of the priest. So the
priest is higher than God. The priest
will decide whether you are forgiven or
not. And God has no choice but to obey
his priest. Isn't that pathetic? That's
arrogance of the highest order. Here's
another statement. The poor sinner
kneels at the confessor's feet. He knows
he's not speaking to an ordinary man,
but to another Christ.
He hears the words, "I absolve thy sins,
and the hideous load of sin drops from
him soul forever. Shall I be a priest?"
These are all Roman Catholic statements.
If any man have an ear, let him hear. He
that leadth into captivity shall go into
captivity.
He that kleth with a sword must be
killed with a sword. Here is the
patience and the faith of the saints.
Revelation 13 9 to10. Now Daniel told us
something more about this power. It told
us that it would change the times and
the laws. Now, we've already discussed
that the papacy changed the law of God.
It took out the second commandment, made
the fourth commandment, now the third
commandment, applied to Sunday rather
than Sabbath, and then it uh divided the
10th commandment into two so that it
still has ten commandments. It's changed
the law. Has it changed the times?
Has Rome changed the times?
Absolutely. Which times has this
changed? Just about everything. Which c
Which calendar are we keeping?
We are keeping the Gregorian calendar.
The Gregorian calendar. Who was Gregory?
He was the pope. Why did Gregory change
the calendar? Because he had to change
the times. You see, he had to change the
times. Now, today is a good day to talk
about this because today is the feast of
Ishtar.
Oh, sorry. Let's rephrase that. Today is
Easter
and the feast of Easter and Easter are
two very different things. Easter, there
is no such thing. You see, the Pash was
determined, the Passover was determined
by the phases of the moon
and the day of the Passover was
determined by the new moon.
So when the new moon came, then the days
were counted and the Passover could take
place on any day. It didn't have to be a
a Friday, a Saturday, and a Sunday. The
Passover could take place on any day
depending on the phase of the new moon.
But the feast of Ishtar
was on the first day of the week. So the
papacy changed the calendar in order to
bring it in line with the feast of
Ishtar. And today they've changed the
rule of the Old Testament where you
count the days and made it apply so that
can only fall on a Sunday.
Only fall on a Sunday whereas in the
past it could fall on any day. Now that
is saying that they distantiate
themselves from the Passover lamb. Even
worse,
if you now by chance, because this can
happen, and it happened just a few years
ago, in fact, I can't remember the exact
date when the pope was in America.
That's exactly when it happened, by the
way. It just so happened that the feast
of Easter and the feast of the Passover
happened to coincide and be on the same
day.
Well, what did they do then? Well, then
they freak. You see, they don't like
that. So the pope then postpones Easter
by one week and that's what they did.
They postponed Easter by one week so
that it dare not fall on the day of the
pash because we want nothing to do with
the lamb that died for us. We serve
another purpose. Ishta is a pagan feast.
So he changed the feast days. He fa
changed the times so that it can fall
into line with that. He changed the
whole calendar to bring it in line with
the pagan feast. And he changed the law
of God.
So the the sword must be killed with a
sword. He who kills with a sword must be
killed with a sword. Here is the
patience of and the faith of the saints.
Revelation 13 9-10. So 1798
the papacy gets a mortal wound, receives
a mortal wound. He is killed with a
sword as he has killed with a sword
before that. And now the prophet looks
around. We have a date 1798. this mortal
wound takes place and I saw another
beast coming up out of the earth.
Now if sea represents peoples,
multitudes, nations, tongues, then what
must earth represent?
A place where you do not have a
multitude of peoples and nations and
tongues. And I saw another beast,
another political entity coming up out
of an area on the planet where there are
not peoples and multitudes and nations.
So it cannot be Europe, it cannot be
Asia, it cannot be those Middle Eastern
countries. Here comes another political
entity. And it had two horns like a
lamb. So it has lamblike principles,
but it'll speak like a dragon. That's
interesting. Revelation 13:11. Now,
who's this power? Well, let's go to the
early reformers. These people were
magnificent. I have so much respect for
these early reformers. John Wesley in
his notes on Revelation 13 written in
17:54
says, "The two-horned beast, he is not
yet come, though he cannot be far off,
for he is to appear at the end of the 42
months of the first beast." Now, the
reformers all clearly said, "Rome is the
antichrist." They were watching it, and
now they say, "Well, this other beast
can't be far off."
The question is which power arises
at exactly at this time in an area where
there are no great multitudes of
nations. There's only one that qualifies
and that would be the United States. Now
many many years ago these
images were already interpreted as such
although the United States was a
relatively insignificant power. Let's
have a look at the rise of the United
States and see if it fits. The
Declaration of Independence was in 1776.
The independence was acknowledged by the
nations of the world in 1783.
In 17887,
a constitution of the United States was
framed.
1791, the Bill of Rights was added.
And in 1798, the very year that Rome
receives a mortal wound, France, the
mightiest power in Europe at that time,
recognizes the independence of the
United States. So the same nation that
gives the papacy a mortal wound in the
same year recognizes the United States.
So it receives a mortal wound. He looked
the prophet and he saw another beast
arise. spot on prophetically.
1863, the Slave Emancipation Act,
similar to what Napoleon did in Europe.
The Eiffel Tower is a symbol of
Freemasonry.
The Statue of Liberty is a symbol of
1798, a very important date. Liberty and
justice for all. That is the lamblike
principle. A dragon, the previous power
said, "Hurry them out of the land or
hang them." So that's how the dragon
speaks and that's how the lamb speaks.
Here is a lamblike principle. Congress
shall make no law respecting the
establishment of religion or prohibiting
the free exercise thereof. Jesus said
the same. Render unto Caesar what is due
unto Caesar and to God what is due unto
God. He didn't come to make uh you force
you into decisions. You can choose,
accept him or reject him, but no
religious test shall ever be required as
a qualification to any office or public
trust under the United States. That's a
lamblike principle. We hold these truths
to be self-evident that all men are
created equal and that they are endowed
by their creator with certain
inalienable rights.
That among these are life, liberty, and
the pursuit of happiness. Oxford history
of the American people. Wonderful
landlike principles. But this
constitution
will have to be changed if there is to
be religious legislation and
persecution. Even the constitution will
have to go. By the way,
we have moved from a republic to a
democracy. America was not a democracy.
It was a republic. You could choose, but
there's a vast difference between a
republic and a democracy. A vast
difference. You know, if 10 wolves and
one lamb have to vote on an issue at
what is for lunch,
the lamb will end up being lunch in a
democracy. It's 10 to one. You
understand? And a republic has totally
different principles to a democracy. The
the constitution is central in a
republic and you cannot just vote it
away. But that seems to have changed.
The Bible says Revelation 13:11, he
spoke like a dragon. Now, the dragon
gave the first power, its seat, and
great authority, and it used it to do
what?
To blaspheme God and to persecute the
saints. Didn't it do that? Exactly. Do
you think the second power could start
doing the same thing? Think it's
possible? Revelation 12:17. And the
dragon was enraged at the woman and went
off to make war against the rest of her
offspring, those who obey God's
commandments and hold to the testimony
of Jesus. Oh, so if you cling to the
word of God and to what the prophets
have said and you obey God's
commandments rather than man's
commandments, do you think you could get
into trouble here with a dragon?
So, he spoke as a dragon. How did this
dragon speak? Let's ask Rome how she
spoke. This is the syllabus of Pope Pius
the 9th given in 1864.
The state has not the right to leave
every man free to embrace whatever
religion he shall deem true. All right,
that was dragon language. The church has
the right to require that the Catholic
religion shall be the religion of the
state to the exclusion of all others.
Cursed be those who assert liberty of
conscience and of worship and such that
maintain that the church may not employ
force. That's dragon language. Pretty
clear.
The Roman Catholic Church must demand
the right to freedom for herself alone.
Catholic statement. The Roman Catholic
is to wield his vote for the purpose of
securing Catholic ascendancy in this
country, Catholic world. July 1870.
That's dragon language.
But Revelation 13:12 says, "It the
second power exercises all the authority
of the first beast
before him."
So it will do the same as the first one
did in the old world.
What then? And causes the earth and
those dwelling in it, how much of the
world is that?
Everybody,
to worship the first beast. Aha.
Now, how do you force someone to worship
the first beast
whose deadly wound was now healed? How
do you force by legislation someone to
worship the first beast? The only way
you can do that is through laws which
govern the conscience. Is that right?
So if the first beast has a rule or
rules and says this is the standard that
I want implemented
and I feel hey I want nothing to do with
that that's contrary to the law of God
and the second power comes along and
says if you don't sizzle fits
what then
then the second power is enforcing laws
of the first power and if I then obey
those laws, then what am I actually
doing?
I'm worshiping the first beast because
it made the laws. Isn't that correct?
And so, I'll be in big trouble with God
because what if those laws are contrary
to the law of God? Then I have to make a
choice. Okay? But that's what the Bible
says. What will happen? The second beast
will do exactly that. and it does great
wonders so that it makes fire come down
from heaven onto the earth in the sight
of men. What is that? That could be
literal fire. And I think we're dealing
with spiritual fire here. And it
deceives those dwelling on the earth.
Now, a literal fire is not very
deceptive. It's pretty painful.
But a spiritual fire that could be
problematic. So this second power will
use deception in order to do this
because of the miracles which were given
to it to do before the beast. So if you
see within the second beast, let's say
the United States, a power that sends a
spirit out, fire, holy spirit, but it is
a false spirit and it is a deceptive
spirit and it is full of miracles and
signs and wonders. Well, then you have a
problem. There's a lecture coming up and
it's called strange fire Tuesday
evening. Whatever you do, don't miss
that lecture. I'm going to show you some
strange fire that you cannot believe.
Which were given to it to do before the
beast, saying to those dwelling on the
earth that they should make an image to
the beast who had the wound and by the
sword and live. How do you make an image
to something? What's an image?
An image is something that looks like
the original. Isn't that right? If I
look into a mirror, what do I see?
I see an image, something that looks
like me, right? It's not me. It's just
an image, but it looks like me. Now, how
did the what did the first beast look
like? The first beast was a religious
power using the state to enforce its
doctrines. Is that correct?
So now what if the second beast becomes
a religious power using the state to
enforce its doctrines, but those
doctrines happen to be the doctrines of
the first beast, Rome, and they're
forcing the whole world to obey Rome.
Wouldn't I be in trouble then? Exactly.
But that's what the Bible says. What
will happen? The second beast will make
laws and enforce them just like the
first one did thereby creating an image
something that is just like the previous
one was and they will enforce laws and
he had power to give life unto the image
of the beast. So this was a pretty
powerful uh political entity that the
image of the beast should both speak and
cause that as many who would not worship
the image of the beast should be killed.
Do you think the United States has the
power to say if you little country don't
listen to me today
you go? Yes or no?
>> I think so. They have the power to do
that and they certainly have done it of
late. Revelation 13:15.
Now, isn't it interesting as we saw
yesterday already that uh even in the
architecture, the one is an image of the
other. Isn't that fascinating?
So, this fascinating building and all
its laws and statutes which are
protected by the constitution. Here is
the first beast. Here's a priest going
into the Vatican. And there is a Swiss
guard representing the state protecting
the church.
Here you have the pope with all the
flags of the nations around him. Is it
possible that the nations of the world
will rally around him? How the pope will
change the world? Essire magazine. He
certainly will. This was the most
charismatic pope of all times. And uh
Ronald Reagan was the one who started
off making a deal which started to
contravene the constitution of the
United States. Harry Truman tried to do
that in 1951. He got such a blast even
from the pulpit of his by his own
minister when he wanted to recognize the
Vatican that he dropped it. But uh
Ronald Reagan, no problem. He just did
it. Even the president's own Baptist
pastor in Washington denounced the idea
from the pulpit when Truman did it. Here
is a Masonic signal picture. Remember
the finger to the mouth? What that
meant?
That is a sign of Horus,
silence, secrecy.
The folded hands mean something. Only
President Ronald Reagan and the Pope
were present in the Vatican library on
that day. One of the earliest goals as
president, Reagan says, was to recognize
the Vatican as a state and to make them
an ally. That's contrary to the American
Constitution.
Both of them received a mini worn wound
and lived. That's not significant. It's
just interesting. Just interesting. It's
almost like the image is following the
beast. John Paul's triumph. Here we have
another signal picture. We have
Gorbachov and the papacy together. They
exchanged some gifts. The party comes to
an end. Communism had served its
purpose. It could go. And the man was
without a country. This was a nice joke
in a South African magazine, the egg
being communism. And he said, "Mahan,
there's nothing in here."
You see, it was a ruse to make people
believe something no other. And then
finally, who would get the credit for
the fall of communism?
If communism had been set up to
subjugate the Orthodox Church and to
eliminate Protestant thinking in the
east of Germany, which it certainly did.
Once it had accomplished that, communism
could go and be dissipated. And who
would get the credit for that?
The pope would get the credit for that.
How do we know that? Because Mary had
already supposedly in Fatima said the
pope will consecrate the whole world to
the immaculate heart of Mary and Russia
will be converted. That was easy to say
because the Bolsheviks had just taken
power in 1917,
the very year when that statement was
made. They knew they had it in the bag.
Not too difficult. The three secrets not
too bad either. The first was a vision
of hell, which makes no sense
whatsoever. The second one was Russia
will be consecrated. They' taken power
anyway. And the third one was that a
future pope would receive a attack on
his life but survive and issue in the
final events. Now if you know history in
advance because you are creating it
that's no problem. Now did the papacy
receive the honor for that? Well let's
ask the presidents of the United States
whether that is so. This is the papal
visit to the United States since
Louisie. Let's ask the then time
President Bill Clinton to tell us what
he thinks.
[applause]
2400 of his faithful here to welcome
him.
He's waving [cheering] to the crowd.
[applause]
Archbishop Regali is alongside the Pope
as he shakes hands with the first lady.
We honor you for helping to lead a
revolution of values and spirit in
central Europe and the former Soviet
Union, freeing millions to live by
conscience, not coercion, and freeing
all of us from the constant fear of
nuclear war.
Your holiness, on behalf of all of us
gathered here today, indeed on behalf of
all the people of our beloved nation, we
welcome you back to America.
>> [cheering]
[applause]
>> Ladies and gentlemen, His Holiness Pope
John Paul II
and
the Vice President of the United States
and Archbishop.
>> So, who received the honor for bringing
down the Soviet Union? The Pope. We
honor you for freeing millions.
So interesting fulfillment of prophecy.
Herman Melman, America has been settled
by people of all nations. All nations
may claim her for their own. We are not
a narrow tribe of men. No, our blood is
as the flood of the Amazon made up of
thousands of noble currents all pouring
into one. We are not a nation so much as
a world. And all the world wandered
after the beasts. Now that means every
single country. Remember the question we
had in the beginning. Do you think it's
possible that every country would be
subject to him? Pope John Paul
superstar.
Now this church,
the Roman church claims to be the mother
of all the churches. Here it says imat
ecclesia, the mother of all the
churches.
Still to be closed is the most important
rift of all between the world's 350
million. That figure has changed
Protestants and about 800 million. That
figure has changed to 1.2 billion by now
today. However, hatchets are being
buried. So, not only in the political
sphere must she gain ascendancy, but
also in the religious sphere. And
that'll take a whole lecture by itself.
Now religiously
all the religions must come together and
be subject to this system. Roma said
this is Pope John Paul 2. This is their
own Catholic magazine Southern Cross in
1995. He said for unity
all churches must accept papal
authority. I have news for you that does
not only include Christian churches that
includes all religions of the entire
world. And then hands across the sea,
Runy and the papacy make a deal
and Christian unity
comes into being. And he performed great
and miraculous signs, even causing fire
to come down from heaven to earth in the
full view of men. Revelation 13:13. So
the second power would now use religion
as an entering wedge for uniting the
world under one system. Question.
In the last few years, has religion
become a topic on this planet? Yes or
no?
Aha. And which religions are
representing
thesis and anti-thesis?
The Judeo-Christian culture pitted
against the Islamic culture and out of
that must come a synthesis. We are
living in interesting times. Because of
the signs he was given power to do on
behalf of the first beast, he deceived
the inhabitants of the earth. Acts
chapter 2:3, they saw what seemed to be
tongues of fire that separated and came
down to rest on them. Is it going to use
some form of religious fervor supposedly
by the Holy Spirit because fire came
down? That was the Holy Spirit's
outpouring upon the people. Is religious
fervor going to bring about the clash?
Do you think that's possible?
Wow. I think it's never been more
possible than today. The Bible, I
believe, is spoton.
The Bible tells us that the United
States of America, which will arise at
exactly the right time, will change its
tune from lamblike principles to dragon
principles and become a persecuting
power just like Rome was of old and that
the whole world would follow this beast.
In our previous section now we saw the
rise of the United States. We saw the
principles of the papal power. We saw
that the Bible predicted that the second
power, the beast out of the earth, would
adopt the same principles as the first
one and enforce them universally. He was
granted power, says Revelation 13:15, to
give breath to the image of the beast,
that the image of the beast should both
speak, so this new religio
political power would make its voice
heard and cause as many as would not
worship the image of the beast to be
killed. You either go along with this or
you're out. So the basic tenant is shape
up or ship out. Isn't that right? That's
it. Shape up or ship out. Well, you
know, the president of the United States
is making noises like that. You're
either for us or against us. Did he say
that? Isn't that interesting? Isn't that
interesting? Church and state, are they
going to work together? Is there going
to be an image, something to pay homage
to? Is the constitution going to be
amended? Great controversy. Page 445.
The image of the beast represents that
form of apostate Protestantism which
will be developed when the Protestant
churches shall seek the aid of the civil
power for the enforcement of their
dogmas.
It is a mistake to apply American
democratic procedures to the faith and
the truth. Time magazine January 1995.
Well, that's contrary to the
constitution. They call that a mistake
these days.
Well, remember he causes all, both small
and great, rich and poor, free and bond,
to receive a mark in their right hand or
in their forehead.
And that no man might buy or sell save
he that had the mark or the name of the
beast or the number of his name. There's
a nice package deal there. Revelation
13:16-17.
Here are the issues that are at stake.
So, if you do not take the mark of the
beast, that's the first piece. So we
have to ask what is the mark of the
first beast? Now today people think that
is a computer mark or a chip in the hand
that might be a means of controlling
buying and selling. And yes there are
devices that have been created to put in
your hand or under the skin of your
forehead which will say where you are
and what your banking details are and
work like a credit card and all these
things. But my question to you is this.
Is a credit card something that dictates
the conscience? Yes or no? Is a dollar
note something that dictates the
conscience? Yes or no? No. What dictates
conscience? Right or wrong? And this is
a mark, a distinguishing feature if you
like of the first beast which is
Catholicism. Is a computer chip a
distinguishing feature of Catholicism?
Yes or no? Or are we dealing with
doctrine? Surely we are dealing with
doctrine. Is God concerned if your can
of beans is scanned by a barcode
and leaves you out of heaven because of
that? Yes or no? Or is God concerned if
you decide not to obey him, but rather
an earthly power contrary to his will?
Would he be concerned then?
>> Yes. It's a question of allegiance.
So yes, maybe there will be a chip.
Maybe they will enforce it on the hand
and enforce it on the forehead.
Whatever. That's not the mark of the
beast because the beast has been defined
as Catholicism.
Did a computer chip change the law of
God? Yes or no? Did a computer chip
persecute the saints? Did a computer
chip change the times? No.
So
buying and selling, you can only do it
if you accept the mark of the beast.
Here is wisdom. Let him that has
understanding count the number of the
beast. For it is the number of a man and
his number is 603 score and six. It is
the number of a what? A man, not of a
can of beans
in Walmart or wherever. Right? It's not
a can of beans. It's the number of a
man.
Well, here's a man. What are the letters
inscribed on the Pope's crown? And what
do they signify of anything? The letters
inscribed on the Pope's miter of
vicarious fel day, which is the Latin
for the vicor of the son of God.
So there it is, Vicario fel.
And if you add that up numerically, if
you give the Latin numerical value to
the names numbers, then you get to
exactly 666.
And
there is no way of getting around that
one. For a while there, this miter
disappeared and the people said there
was no such title. But of course, it is
in the articles of the papacy, though
they cannot deny that that title
literally exists. Triple 6 symbolizes
the union of error.
In Greek, you have Greek numerical
value. The Latin kingdom, Helatina
Basallayia. If you add the Greek
numerical value, you get to 666. The
Italian church, Italica ecclesia, 666.
The Latin speaking man. These are all
official titles of the papacy. They all
work out to 666.
That's interesting. So, the the system
has a number 666. and the man the
antichristto
vicario fi
vicor of god here on earth it means
literally in the place of Jesus Christ
that's what it means so in actual fact
the papacy says call me in the place of
Jesus Christ in the place of his auntie
call me antichrist couldn't have done us
a bigger favor he identifies himself
mark of the beast what is that first we
must understand God's mark, his seal or
his sign. And I saw another angel
ascending from the east having the seal
of the living God. Remember we discussed
this when we discussed the earlier
chapters of Revelation cried with a loud
voice and was given him to earth the sea
saying hurt not the earth neither the
sea till we have sealed the servants of
our God in the forehead so settled in
them in the truth that they cannot be
moved. A seal authenticates a document.
So the president has a seal. Moreover, I
gave them my Sabbaths that there might
be a sign between me and them that they
might know that I am the Lord that
sanctifies them. Ezekiel 20:12. And of
course, if you take that sign, it's oat.
It means a mark. God has a mark.
So God's seal contains his name, his
title, his territory. I the Lord Yave,
his title, creator, territory, heaven
and earth. It's in the heart of his law.
Remember the Sabbath day to keep it
holy. Six days you shalt labor and do
all thy work. But the seventh day is the
Sabbath of the Lord your God. For why?
In six days Yave the Lord made creator
heaven and earth. By the way, remove the
Sabbath as we have said before and the
entire law has no stamp of authority. It
could be from Joshmo.
But because the Sabbath is in there, the
entire law gets its authority from none
other than the creator of heaven and
earth. So now, what if you take this law
and you modify it and you put a
different stamp on there? What do you do
then?
What happens then? So, Satan has
attacked the Sabbath because it is the
seal of God. It is the mark of authority
which makes the whole of the law valid.
Remember Daniel 7:25. He will think to
change times and laws. Well, let's ask
the pope whether he does that.
Episcop. The pope has power to change
times, to abregate laws, to dispense
with all things even the precepts of
Christ. That's pretty arrogant. He can
do whatever he likes. No wonder he has
the sign of Horus
on his lapel over there. That's the
symbol of Horus, by the way.
Jesus Christ the same yesterday and
today and forever. Hebrews 13:8. Jesus
doesn't change. So why should the papacy
have the right to change the law of God?
What specifically is the mark of the
beast? Well, what's the best way of
finding out?
Isn't the best way of finding out?
Asking. Why don't we ask them, what's
your mark?
The mark of the beast must be a sign of
the Roman church's authority, mustn't
it? Let's ask them. Cardinal Gibbons.
Of course, the Catholic Church claims
that the change was her act, changing
Sabbath to Sunday. and the act is a mark
of her ecclesiastical power and
authority in religious matters. So she
claims it is her mark of power. Here's
another statement. Catholic record
September 1, 1923.
Sunday is our mark of authority.
The church is above the Bible and this
transference of Sabbath observant is
proof of that fact. So this is a in
yourrface God. We the church have power
to change your law and our stamp of
approval that we can do it. Our seal is
that we change the day of worship by the
way which is the international day of
worship today.
Sunday. Sunday. That's right. In Muslim
countries, the day of worship is on
Friday. But on which day is are the
stores closed?
>> Sunday.
>> On Sunday. That's right. In Israel, the
day is the Sabbath. But on which days
are the banks closed
on Sunday. And the minister of the
interior wants to introduce Sunday as
the second rest day. That's interesting,
says the Pope. Get on with it. Get on
with the world government. On his tour
to Poland, Pope John Paul denounced
excessive materialism and the separation
of church and state. time 17 1991.
So what about the union of church and
state where the American constitution
separates them? I want to hear some
Americans stand up and shout, "Give us
justice. Give us decency and to hell
with the Constitution."
That was the Catholic news already in
1963.
This is Renquest. He's the chief justice
of the n of the United States. He said,
"The wall of separation between church
and state is a metaphor based on bad
history." That's a sad statement.
Wow.
A metaphor which has proved useless as a
guide to judging it should be frankly
and explicitly abandoned.
Okay. Is the United States beginning to
speak like a dragon? Yes or no? It's
very much dragon language. There it is.
Ranquest said these very words. a
metaphor based on bad history. Here's
Keith Tunia, Time magazine 1995. He
said, "The wall of separation between
church and state that was erected by
secular humanists." Hello, can they
twist the truth and other enemies of
religious freedom? I thought it was put
there by the friends of religious
freedom, didn't you? Well, has to come
down. Those opposing our views are the
new fascists. Now that's interesting.
This is the pot calling the kettle
black. Isn't that fascinating? So now a
fascist is calling a fascist a fascist.
That is Jesuit dlectic thinking. It's
brilliant. It's so clever because only a
fascist can make a rule dictating
conscience.
And if you refuse to obey a rule because
you accept another rule, then you by
principle here are a fascist because you
are accepting a totalitarian regime.
You're accepting God. But they are
accepting another one and that's the
states. You see, fascinating
the clash is becoming interesting. St.
Louis Post Dispatch, as the second
century of the Bill of Rights draws to a
close, the Supreme Court is redefining
what religious liberty will mean in the
third century. Broadly, the court's new
approach helps conventional religions
while hurting unconventional ones. You
better join the ship or else. Is that
what it says? Okay. It gets worse. I am
the bearer of bad news.
But fortunately,
I am all cheerful about it. Have you
noticed?
And uh that's something people find very
hard to understand.
I'm all cheerful about it. Not because I
have discovered this, because I haven't.
I'm just a parrot repeating what many
people have discovered.
I'm cheerful about it because it is the
fulfillment of prophecy. And when
prophecy is fulfilled, it tells me who
is in control. Who's in control? God is
in control. And as it fulfills, I know
I'm going home soon. And the sooner the
better. Get on with it. Finish it so
that we can go home.
No more tears. No more crying. No more
crime. No more death. No more rape. No
more terrible things that happen to
little children. All of it gone. No more
keys. No more anything. Wow. That'll be
just great. It seems to be plain. This
is Justice William O'Don O. Douglas, it
seems to be plain that by these laws,
the states compel one under sanction of
law to refrain from work or recreation
on Sunday because of the majority's view
on that day. The state by law makes
Sunday a symbol of respect or adherence.
Pad Robertson said, "The next obligation
that a citizen of God's world order owes
to is to himself. Remember the Sabbath
day to keep it holy is a command for the
personal benefit of each citizen. Higher
civilizations rise when people can rest
and draw inspiration from God. Laws in
America that mandated the day of rest,
Sunday laws, have been nullified as a
violation of separation of church and
state
as an outright insult to God. Oh, isn't
that interesting? And his plan only
those policies that can be shown to have
a clearly secular purpose are
recognized.
So what is he saying?
Forget about that stupid constitution
that separates church and state. Let's
do something else. Let's get church and
state together. Can you see an image of
the beast arising here?
Wow. This is fascinating stuff. So,
church and state will work together and
legislate laws which will honor the
first beast. Who changed the Sabbath to
Sunday? The Roman Catholic Church. If
they enforce Sunday, who will they be
honoring?
Rome. They will be honoring Rome. And
then Sunday Times 571 1998, Pope
launches crusade to save Sunday.
Make it clear that Sunday must not be
worked since it must be celebrated as
the day of our Lords.
He brought out a whole encyclical. I'm
just going to breeze through it. He says
it's tradition. They celebrate the
eukarist. He talks about an encyclical
reum and he asks for laws legislating
respect their duty to keep Sunday holy.
He asks for civil legislating
legislation which will enable us to keep
Sunday. Now the United States should say
our constitution forbids this. I'm
terribly sorry Mr. Pope but church and
state are separate. We cannot concur.
Did they do that? No.
Here's the statement.
There is Bush. Just after he became
president, he cut the ribbon to this new
museum, this multi-million dollar Roman
Catholic museum. And he says the best
way to honor Pope John Paul 2, truly one
of the great men, is to take his
teachings seriously, is to listen to his
words and put his words and teachings
into action here in America.
And that's the highest official in the
government saying, "Let's listen to the
pope." Is that removing the separation
between church and state? Yes or no?
Absolutely. This is a challenge we must
accept.
I have a problem with you, Mr.
President. You are speaking like a
dragon,
isn't he? Absolutely. Is he fulfilling
prophecy? Yes. Am I angry with him? No.
pleased that he's there and can fulfill
the prophecy because that means we can
go home. He exercises all the power of
the first beast. Has he got power to
tell nations and individuals what to do?
Yes or no? Absolutely.
And causes the earth and them that dwell
therein to worship the first beast. You
better obey that system whose deadly
wound was healed. Rub two religions up
long enough and one will rise like a
mushroom to defend itself. Right.
The unrestrained freedom of thinking and
of openly making knowns one's thoughts
is inherent in the rights of citizens
and is by no means to be reckoned worthy
of favor and support. Pope Gregory,
you're not allowed to tell what you are
thinking anymore.
That's what the Pope said. Pope Gregory
said that. Fascinating stuff. Is America
beginning to say the same things?
Hasn't the president says those that say
such and such and such and such are the
new terrorists, you better not say
anything against us or else. Did he say
that? Oh yes, he's saying the same
thing. Interesting. And we've seen this
one. If we gain sufficient numerical
majority in this country, religious
freedom is at an end. Bishop of St.
Louis, November 23, 1851. Religious
freedom is rapidly coming to an end.
There was a Sunday law in the past. On
the venerable day of the sun, let the
magistrates and people residing in the
cities rest and let all workshops be
closed.
That was the addict of Constantine.
Christians shall not doize. Now, this is
the fascinating part. You know, if the
world makes a national Sunday law and
says, "There you go. Everybody must rest
on Sunday," I will say, "Okay, that's
fair enough. I don't care. give me one
more day off.
If they say everybody must keep
Wednesday and Thursday and Friday as
well, I'll say, "Well, that's great. Now
I can stay home all week." You know what
I mean? But there's something else to
this law. Look what this law also said.
Besides not working on Sunday, what did
it say? Christians shall not jewise,
they may not keep the Sabbath and be
idol on Saturday. Aha. So the law must
say something more. It must prevent me
from obeying God.
Interesting. But shall work on that day.
But the Lord's day they shall especially
honor. Now the same happened with
Pharaoh. Pharaoh issued a decree
and uh Moses came up to Pharaoh and said
this is not going to happen. And Pharaoh
said to him, "You, Moses, you make the
people rest."
And the word rest that is used there in
the Old Testament is Shabbat.
You make the people Shabbat. Keep the
Sabbath. I am telling you to your works
increase their labor. No more straw
gathering for them. Let them work. So
what law did Pharaoh made make? He made
an anti-Sabbath law. So, did Constantine
make an anti-Sabbath law?
At the same time, it was a pro- Sunday
law. Yes, but that's not the important
thing for me. The important thing here
is that he forbade one to not work on a
Sabbath. And Pharaoh did the same thing.
Now what was God's response to Pharaoh
when Pharaoh said I am going to force
you to work on the Sabbath day?
What happened?
Plagues came and sorted him out. Now the
Bible says there will be plagues at the
end of time to sort such a power out.
Right or wrong, the parallels are
absolutely fantastic.
From the apostles time until the council
of Ledia, which was 364, the holy
observation of the Jews Sabbath
continued, as may be proved out of many
authors, yay, notwithstanding the decree
of the council against it. So the early
Christians ignored the papal decrees
that the Sabbath was kept,
notwithstanding the decree of the
council against it. It's also seen in
the fact that Pope Gregory I wrote
against the Roman citizens, forbid any
work done on the Sabbath day. That means
Sunday people were working on it. So the
f early church kept the
Saturday. Now here's an interesting
decree issued by the first beast. This
is the Roman Catholic Church at the
Senate of Tulus in AD 1163.
They issued the following decree. The
bishop and priests take care and to
forbid under pain of excommunication
every person from presuming to give
reception or at least assistance to the
following of this heresy which was
Sabbathkeeping. This was the decree
against the Valdenzas who chose
biblically to keep the Sabbath of the
Lord. So the pope said heresy this will
not happen. Wherever they shall be
discovered, neither were they to have
any dealings with them in buying and
selling. Oops.
So the first beast issued a decree that
those who kept the Sabbath would receive
economic boycott, no buying or selling.
That being so deprived of the common
assistance of life, they might be
compelled to repent of the evil of their
way. Whoever shall dare to contravene
this order, let them be excommunicated
as a partner with them in guilt. As many
of them as can be found, let them be
imprisoned by the Catholic prince
princes and punished with a forfeite of
all their substance.
That was a Roman Catholic decree. You
cannot buy and sell if you continue
Sabbathkeeping and we will take
everything you own away.
And then did they listen the Valdenzers?
No. So what was the next thing that then
happened?
Kingdons of Aragon banished all the
Valdenzias in n in 1194 as a
consequence. And then they sent in the
military and they decimated them. They
killed them. So there was a Sunday law.
There was an anti-Sabbath law included
in that. And there was no buying and
selling and a death decree. That's what
the first beast did. Do you think the
second beast might become like the first
one? Do you think it's possible? Do you
think the image might do the same thing?
Well, it just said so. All businesses
here, Harold Linsel, editor of
Christianity Today, all businesses,
including gasoline stations and
restaurants, should close every Sunday
by force of legislative fear through the
duly elected officials of the people.
So, they're asking for the same thing.
The Bible predicts a coming confederacy
of religions in America attempting to
unite church and state. And the people
must be whipped up into a religious
fervor
by a outpouring of a spirit with signs
and wonders which will make them
convinced that God is with the movement.
Does that make sense?
It's scary. Eh, I think it's scary.
So the coming crisis is similar to that
which was in the day of Daniel. The
Babylonian king, a powerful world leader
established a counterfeit image and
compelled worship contrary to God's
command.
And the worthies they refused to bow
down to the image and as a consequence
there were major problems. Daniel
chapter 3:15 says how this religious
ceremony was conducted. Now when you
hear the sound of
what does it say? All kinds of music. If
you are ready to fall down and worship
the image I made, very good. But if you
do not worship it, you will be thrown
immediately into a blazing furnace. Do
you think music could be important in
whipping up a religious fervor?
What about all kinds of music? What
would that include? That would include
light pop music. That would include, for
those that love it, beautiful opera
music. That would include heavy rock.
That would include heavy metal. That
would include all kinds of things. Don't
you think? As long as the people accept
the religious fervor, who cares?
Music will play a very prominent role.
Do you know that the Bible repeats that
three times as if the Lord is really
trying to say something? Well, let's
have a look what happened when the pope
visited St. Louis and the youth was
filling the chamber and two monks out
here. I think these look like
Franciscans according to their address.
They said at last we have unity, unity,
peace, peace on earth. Now what does the
Bible say when they start saying what?
Peace. Peace. Then we have a problem.
And then as the pope comes in, you will
see the young people go hysterical.
All kinds of music is being used to
satisfy the hunger of all their souls.
From beautiful choir music by
ecuomanical choirs of all religions
singing together to pop music with arms
rising and nuns waving their arms and
the youth to heavy rock by DC Talk and
bands like that. As the pope comes in,
then we have dancing in the Lord and all
these f features and the Roman Catholic
priest is speaking to one of the uh DJs
there and he says the the DJ asks him or
the the reporter asks the Roman Catholic
priest, do you think there is any
religion in this loud music?
And uh the priest says, "Of course,
music is God is in all the great music
systems of the world. The great music of
the reformation. And this music, well,
the young people understand it. That's
good enough. Well, let's watch and see
what happens."
>> It was great. A great feeling of
excitement of peace.
>> Unity of love. Peace. Love and unity.
>> Unity.
>> Yes.
>> All nations [singing and music] will
come.
>> All nations will come. worship before
you Lord [music]
and worship before you.
Now all the nations bowed down.
Next nation.
[singing]
>> [music]
>> My God.
Well, in this video clip, I only showed
you the nations coming. I can't show you
the whole thing. We'll be here all day.
But representatively all the nations in
every corner came and bowed down to the
pope. The music and the other issues
which I mentioned set the stage for the
young people and for the older people.
I'll be showing you that clip in another
lecture as we continue along this
interesting path. So the world is ready
to accept this authority. But the Bible
says in Romans 6:16, "Know ye not that
to whom you yield yourself servants to
obey, he servants you are to whom you
obey, whether of sin unto death or of
obedience unto righteousness."
So if we obey this system and they've
asked for laws, the papacy has asked for
laws and the president of the United
States says, "As you exhort, we will
listen. We must introduce this into the
United States." The churches are
clamoring for legislation regarding the
law of God. But Jesus says,
"Come and follow me."
Now, this is the basis of Revelation
chapter 13. Revelation chapter 13
describes the two political powers which
in essence control the world at the end
of time. The one in the middle ages
totally Catholic, the other one now
representing Protestantism and doing
exactly the bidding of the first beast.
Has Protestantism Protestantism totally
changed
or has Protestantism been infiltrated?
That is a good question. Now we will
still have to see and we'll have to do a
lecture to find out whether
Protestantism has been infiltrated and
whether the great Protestant preachers
really are what they say they are. We
will also have to look at this fire,
this outpouring of the spirit of God in
adverted commas which is flooding the
United States of the world and not only
the United States but the entire world
through the media.
Is it the right one or is it not the
right one? And what must be our
criteria?
The word of God. That's all we have. So
you will see there are some lectures
coming which are called
that all may be one in strange fire.
Don't miss those lectures. They're going
to be very very revealing and we will
paint in this picture and we will see
that God has predicted 100% what was
going to happen on this planet. And that
is why I can lift up my head and be
pleased because God is in control. Jesus
is going to be the ultimate victor.
Thank you.
Hallelujah.
[music]
Oh,
hallelujah.
Hey,
oh
go
Heat. Heat.
Oh,
go
down.